Good Morning John, and good morning nerdfighters
Today we're going to have a special episode of Question Tuesday where we answer real questions from real nerdfighters
Hank: This time with my real Dad! And my real Mom!
Sydeny: That's me
Hank: All so your real dad and real mom, unless you've got something you wanna tell us..?
Sydeny: not today
Hank: So, how are you feeling?
Mike: nervous.. I don't do in front of the camera
Hank: Dad makes films!
Hank: ummm.. this is where we got it from
Mike: nooo.. Hank: *laughing* Mike: no, you did a whole new better thing
Hank: First question I have for you is from Ingus
Hank: "Why did you name your son William if you were gonna call him Hank?"
Sydeny: *sighs*
Mike: *laughing* I would also like to know the answer to this question! Because the bank doesn't like it
Sydeny: Okay, because we're southern!
Sydeny: We wanted to name you after your grandfathers
Sydeny: So that was William Henry
Mike: didn't want you to be the Bill or Will Hank: or Will Mike: or Willy
Mike: We liked Hank, we thought it was cute, baby Hank
Mike: But I realize it's been a monumental pain in the ass for you your whole life!
Hank: I remember being like thirteen years old and not knowing how to spell William
Hank: "Did you have alternate names for us if we were going to be girls"
Hank: Do I have a girl name out there, somewhere?
Sydeny: Not for you, I knew you were a boy
Hank: How did you know I was a boy? Magic Witchcraft?
Sydeny: Yes, pretty much
Hank: But you did have one for John?
Sydeny: yes, Elizabeth
Hank: How did it feel when I came out a boy?
Mike: I was perfectly fine with that
Hank: *laughing*
Mike: Mostly happy that you were out and breathing
Hank: 10 fingers and 10 toes
Mike: You were a little blue
Hank: Yeaah
Mike: yeah Hank: I didn't have the best birth Mike: but you weren't real bad blue you, didn't have a real high apgar score
Mike: John's grades were higher even then
Hank: What is an apgar score? Do they just take-
Mike: It's a color score
Hank: They just have a color chart?
Mike: They do, yeah they do
Hank: And they just line it up and they go-
Mike: Yeah that's absolutely what I think it is- but I- based on my political science degree
Hank: What was John like as a child
Sydeny: Horible
Both: wow
Hank: Didn't even let me finish the sentence Sydeny: *laughing*
Mike: He was a wonderful child
Hank: *laughing*
Mike: He was a little troubled Sydeny: unique has my mother would say
Mike: ..lonely Sydeny: John was always into embellishing the truth
Mike: We're walking through the Miami airport and he's like..
five you're three and we're carrying you
and he's walking carrying this little bag and he just lies down calmy
No tantrum, he just lies down on his back in the airport and says:
"It's just to much, I can't take it any more"
Hank: *laughing*
Sydeny: One time you (Hank) just got tired of him yelling at you, and you took a hammer to him
Sydeny: Cause you couldn't talk really at that time, you were-
Hank: Why did I have a hammer?!
Sydeny: umm, I don't know..
Hank: Mom
Sydeny: yes?
Hank: "How did you raise such perfect children?"
Sydeny: *laughing* Mike: *laughing*
Hank: "Do your friends and family understand what we do? John and I?
Sydeny: They clearly understand what John does.. Do they understand what you do and the videos and everything else? Hank: Yeah that stuff
Sydeny: Noo.. no
Sydeny: Noo Mike: It always surprise me ad kind of amuses me that there are people who go:
Mike "Is Hank okay with the fact that John is so famous and so successful
Hank: I'm not though
Mike: *laughing*
Hank: You think I am
Hank: Jessie wants to know "Has anyone really been far even as decided to use even go want to do look more like?"
Sydeny: Yes!
Mike: "What's your number one parenting tip?"
Mike: encourage
Hank: Wow, just one word too
Sydeny: Your father would say your number one marriage tip is persistence
Hank: *laughing*
Sydeny: and maybe my number one parenting tip is along the same lines
Hank: Henry Reich says- you know Henry Mike: oh, yeah
Hank: "How did you decide to live where you do?"
Mike: We live near Ashville, 20 minutes outside of Ashville
Mike: Spreadsheet that had indicators
Sydeny: Social well being and individual well being
Mike: And almost all the indicators came from the cenus
Hank: So, you used math, is that what your saying? You mathed your way to your new home?
Sydeny: Yes, god were such nerds!
Hank: What is up with this?
Sydeny: My friend made it, she's wearing Schnelle. Look she's got bloomers
Hank: She's got bloomers.. yeah she does
Hank: Thanks for being my mom
Sydeny: Oh, thanks for being my son!
Hank: thanks for supporting us.. uh, throughout all of this, also as, you know,  my dad throughout all of the rest of my life
Hank: Everybody my dad!
Hank: *clapping* *clapping noise in background*
Hank: I'm gonna put in applause there
Sydeny: I personally love the fact that it's time for project for awesome, that;s my favorite time of year
Sydeny: Byee!